hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from the feed a 2020 online
olympiad
uh it's uh clash india versus poland and
this is match two so the return match in
the first match apollon defeated india
42
uh with duda beating anand on board one
uh and uh rather slovachek
beating uh vidit on board two and now
india needs a win to get back into the
match so this is a really crazy game
i didn't show any of the games of the
olympia so far as i've been i've been
very busy
uh but i will show some of them uh from
the semi-finals and also from the finals
so let's just
update this as um uh forgot to update
this there we go
uh so let's check it out really a wild
game and the duda opens with
d4 uh sorry about that
uh with knight to f6 by anand uh and
c4 we have e6 and knight the c3 inviting
ana to do an im so indian
uh which anand goes for so bishop to b4
the names of indian defenses on the
board and e3
going for the for the classical line uh
we have castles by on and end
bishop to d3 just continuing development
with d5
uh all standard names of stuff and the
knight to f3 we have capture sun c for
bishop captures and
now striking in the center with c5 you
could also go for b6 with the idea of
just switching
uh trading of the bishops with bishop to
a6 but alan chooses a a different
approach so c5 this is the most popular
line uh we have
a3 and bishop captures on c3 now we have
b captures and
queen to c7 now threatening captures on
d4
opening up the attack on the bishop and
here usually you're going to move the
bishop either to a2 or or e2 now maybe
b3
as in in some rare cases uh but here
duda goes for bishop to e2 with b6
now preparing to put this bishop on this
beautiful diagonal and
another just castles with bishop to b7
and the duda is very happy with with his
development
uh we have knights the e5 by anand
getting the knight to uh to this very
nice outpost and now
uh no moves here are rook to d8 and
knight b to d7 but to do the
anand goes for knight to c6 and it is as
of move 12 that we have a completely new
game
so do the traits here we have captures
captures and now to avoid
checkmate you have to play something
with bishop to f3 uh it looks very nice
but you don't
actually get to trade off the dark
square bishop as
the light square bishop as 94 and black
will be very happy with this excellent
outpost for the knight he's going to
play f5 cement that night and
uh pl play the game on so here instead
after queen captures on c6 with f3
do that prevents checkmate and also
takes away these squares from from
anon's knight
and rook f to d8 now uh aligning
the rook nicely with the queen and the
maybe soon to be open d
file bishop to b2 and now knight to d5
uh this knight is now coming uh well uh
you you want to get the knight over to
a4 and from a4
uh sorry uh to uh a5 and from a5 the
knight will be extremely strong
so queen d2 and now we have b5
uh we have e4 kicking the knight back
and the knights to
b6 uh to a4 i meant with rook
after d1 and now knights to a4 and here
knight is on an excellent square putting
pressure on the bishop putting pressure
on c3
at some point you might play c4 if d5
you might even get some squares on b3
and d3
uh who knows one of the one of the cases
where knight is actually very very
useful on the rim
so rook ate the b1 preparing bishop to
a1 and now
although this bishop could be strong at
some point the the knight
will also be very strong so anand of
course doesn't trade the knight for the
bishop we have a6 and now bishop to a1
we have c4 by anand now uh getting the
the b3 square is an outpost if at some
point the d5 is played if we do that
tries to create a pass pawn
then you might be able to go something
like knight c5 knight b3 or knight
to d3 we have queen to f4 by
duda and now the immediate f5 violence
sort of gambiting upon but not really
because rook to f8 will will win back
the pawn
uh but the duda does capture he goes e
captures on f5 and now anand just
attacks it rook to f8 so uh preparing to
recapture it with rook to e1 by duda
and knight to b6 there's no russian
recapturing the pawn
and now if you try to defend the pawn
with something like g4 that's uh
that's way too adventurous captures
captures knight d5 attacks the queen you
can easily bring the
rook into the attack easily uh attack
the
the pawn win it later and it's not going
to be much of a problem and the white's
king side is ruined so after knight b6
we have bishop to d1
now shifting the bishop over to c2 and
here we have
knight to d5 pushing the queen back and
only then will anand recapture the pawn
uh queen to d2 and now e captures on f5
uh with bishop to c2 and now queen to d6
uh with bishop to b2 now you need to
guard both of these pawns the knight
constantly puts pressure on the c3 pawn
and the queen constantly now puts
pressure on the eighth response so
bishop to b2
not the most active square for the
bishop but
uh what are you gonna do so bishop to c6
by anand
and now rook to e5 a very nice rook lift
preparing rook
uh b to e1 with f4 now creating another
excellent outpost for the knight here on
e3
and the rook beat the e1 finally
doubling up those rooks but now knight
to e3 disconnecting the rooks and you
are not easily getting rid of this knife
from e3
so bishop to c1 preparing queen to f2 to
eliminate the knight from e3
and now uh rook 8 e8 and here uh it's
very very interesting if you go for
captures captures then it's
uh it's a very very easy for black to
play this you could try
uh queen to f2 but then the knight just
returns to b5 constantly putting
pressure on
on this pawn and the black will be very
happy uh
trading off the rooks as it's not going
to be easy for white to ever activate
this dark square bishop you just don't
want to trade this knight for the bishop
so instead anand uh duda goes queen to
f2 right away now preparing to capture
an e3
but now anand just goes back he says i'm
very happy to trade both of the rooks
but
uh you you do need to take care of these
pawns constantly
so bishop back to b2 do the defense them
and only now rook captures on e5 we have
d
captures and queen e6 and now while the
light square bishop is very strong the
dark square bishop is pretty much
stuck here doing absolutely nothing so
bishop back to c1 but now bishop to e8
preparing the counter the light square
bishop on this diagonal and if we trade
off the light square bishops then it's
going to be this dark square bishop
which isn't doing all that much
against this excellent knight so bishop
to e4
dude i would gladly even trade off the
bishop for a knight
uh but now he kind of gives up the c3
pawn but not really
here anand grabs the pawn uh but the
duda finds the very interesting
bishop captures on h7 check and now
uh if you don't capture it if you just
play something like king to h8 then you
you can just go bishop back to c2 and
nothing happens but anand decides it's
okay to do this
king captures on h7 queen the c2 with
check
bishop to g6 now and the queen captures
on c3 so you want back your
your piece and your pawn but you've uh
helped white get this bishop on this
beautiful diagonal
and it's still not clear what are you
going to do with your dark square bishop
but if black isn't able to do anything
uh
either then it's not going to be that
much of a problem and here on goes
bishop to d3
uh bishop to d3 he's clearing the path
for the g pawn he wants to play g5 g4
bust open the king side
rook to d8 on the other hand was also
also very very dangerous but it comes
with
uh with the temporary sacrifice of the
f4 pawn so if you allow duda to capture
it rook d3 attacks the queen
queen b2 and now you can start pushing
your pass pawn pawn c3 pawn c2 the
bishop already covers
the c2 square would be very dangerous
but anand has a different plan he goes
bishop to d3
makes way for the g pawn and queen to d
for now
uh we have g5 by anand and now bishop to
d2
uh we have g4 uh preparing to bust open
the
the position so do the captures on g4
with
f3 and now captures we have captures by
anand
and now bishop to e3 uh as it can get
very dangerous for example if you move
the rook from from the back rank rook to
f1 is extremely strong then queen the c6
could come will be extremely strong
so duda plays bishop to e3 he prepares a
queen to a7 check
and here we have something extremely
weird that happens anna plays queen to
f7
uh of course now if rook to f1 lands
that's uh that's just game
so duda plays a quinta a7 offering a
queen trade and now
what uh you could do is that you could
just trade queens here and then play
something like a5 b4
uh try and create more pass pawns here
on the queen side and
try and uh make something of that but
here annan plays king to g6 and that's
an extremely weird move because it gives
up a full pawn
while not gaining all that much because
duda captures it with
check and you don't have any ways of
improving the activity of your king you
have to go back so king h7 violent and
now queen to a7
again attacking the queen here king the
g8 and only now do the trades with queen
captures on f7 we have king captures and
now bishop the c5
and here uh it's four pawns to two in
duda's favor
and uh well it it's just weird uh for an
honor to give up this a6 pawn like that
uh but
king e6 you don't want to allow e6 e7
and now duda needs to push for the win
he's up two pawns
let's see how he does king to g2 by duda
and now
rook to f7 getting back with the rook
bishop to b4
uh and now rook to c7 anand also has a
pass pawn so of course he wants to push
it with
h4 duda now prepares to push both of his
pawns on the king side
uh and the c3 uh by anand with h5
and c2 and of course now bishop to d2
guarding the queening square twice
rook to d7 preparing some nasty
discoveries to maybe capture the bishop
here
so bishop to c1 uh we have bishop to h7
and now g5 preparing g6 and so on
but here anand finds rook to d1 and now
it's uh it's a question what do you do
your rook is under attack and your
bishop is under attack
so while it is a very interesting idea
duda says i'm not very
impressed by this and duda just plays g6
attacking the bishop
so you're on and here pause the video
what do you do here well i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
not falling for dudas bluff and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
uh it's actually bishop captures here if
you just go for the rook then pong
captures and there is
nothing you can do against uh against
queen you have to go for
captures and then you get a queen and a
very very likely black will also get a
queen but it's uh
uh it's hard to imagine that you will be
able to get out of any checks so instead
of this g6 move that you do that played
dude i should have just gone
king to f2 defend the rook and then of
course he just continues enjoying his uh
uh his uh material advantage but here
after g6 ana played bishop captures on
g6 and now it's a
it's a different story because if you
capture the pawn now then just rook
captures on e1 and there's nothing to do
the king easily stops the past pawn
so here after bishop captures on g6 dude
and needs to defend the rook and now
uh the bishop captures an h5 and anand
just gobbled up those two pawns and now
the material on the board is completely
equal
so first anand gives up the a6 pawn and
then duda gives up the two connected
pass pawns on the queen
king side that's really really crazy
so bishop to b2 now and bishop to g4 now
it's anand who will be pushing for for
more than the draw we have rook to g1
and now bishop to f5 defending the pawn
and now
uh anand's plan is very simple he wants
to get the king over to b3 and that's
gonna be game so rook to e1
king to d5 and now the problem is if you
just wait for anand to bring his king
closer it's not enough
for for duda to hold for example bishop
e6 you need to stop the pawn
bishop b2 if you just wait king c4
bishop c1 king b3
and that's pretty much it rookie three
check you're gonna go king a2
king the uh somewhere or rook to e1
king to b1 and that's just it the bishop
is gonna fall or you're gonna play
something like bishop to d2 but then
just captures
captures and of course you promote to a
queen and of course this is not winning
you you're just going to eliminate this
pawn get your king over here and push
the pawn
so this is what happens if you just wait
for anant to bring his king closer so
here we have e6
uh by duda uh trying to get some
advantage
uh or some more activity with his pieces
but uh
it's not not all that much bishop
captures an e5
on e6 we rook the e5 check king to d6
now
and rook the e uh sorry rook back to e1
you need to guard against uh
pawn to c1 with bishop to c4 and now
rook to g1 now duda is just forced to
repeat here and
wait and see what anand will do but
anand just goes in with the king king c5
we have rook to g5 with check and bishop
to d5 blocking
rook g1 you have to guard a queening
square king c4 rook g4 check we have
king to b3
and now rook to b4 with check king a2 by
anand
and here we have king the e3 but now
uh once again pause the video and win
this game for on and well
well i'll give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on not going for
the most
obvious move uh as if you do this then
yes you get the queen captures captures
but it's still not going to be easy
uh if you if you go for this then white
will capture here and you're gonna
you're you're gonna you know work uh
very very hard for your meal probably
probably not gonna be able to do it with
very little time on the clock
uh so here after king the e3 anand
played bishop to b3 he just uh
locked out this rook from the defense of
the bishop but rook to b1 is also
sufficient just going after the bishop
but bishop to b3
was played by anand and he was in this
position almost 69
that uh young sister duda resigned the
game and not only did
unretaliate but it was also enough for
india to win the match against poland
uh and go into the finals of defeated
2020 online olympiad
it wasn't so simple i'll show you the
standings here of both matches here you
have it
like i said in the first game in poland
142 with
both uh duda and voiter defeating anand
and vidit on uh
board one and two uh but then in the
second game
uh as you can see both anand witted
hampi konero and harika ronawali won
their games and the score was four and a
half one and a half and then
armageddon was played and the armageddon
uh game
fell to the board uh jumpy canero versus
monica sochko and jack mcconner was
victorious and that brought
india to the finals of defeated 2020
olympiad
where they will face i'm not gonna
mention who they're gonna face as
we might cover one of the games from
that match from the united states versus
russia match
uh so i'm not gonna spoil it just yet uh
but yeah
that's the game uh i do hope you enjoyed
it congratulations to india on reaching
the finals we'll see what happens in the
finals
i would like to thank barry mcmurdock
eric novak uh corey tolliver
david kimura and the gear schecter for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
olympia finals checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank y'all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
sunday